Here's the diagonalization trick
applied to Turing machines.
We'll let M1, M2, etcetera,
be the set of all Turing machines.
Turing machines can be
described as strings, so
there are a countable number of them,
so we can enumerate them like this.
And we'll create a table as before.
I'll define the function
f(i,j) to be one, if machine i
accepts the description of machine j and
we'll define it as zero otherwise.
For this example I'll fill
out the table somehow.
The actual values aren't
important right now.
Now consider the language L
consisting of string descriptions
of machines that do not accept
their own descriptions.
And let's add a Turing machine,
which we'll call ML that recognizes
this language to the grid.
Well, again, we run into a problem.
This row is supposed to
have the opposite values
of what's along the diagonal.
But what about the diagonal
element of this row?
What does the machine do when
it's given its own description?
If it accepts itself,
then ML is not in the language,
so ML should not have accepted itself.
On the other hand, if ML does not
accept its string representation,
then ML isn't a language, so ML should
have accepted its string representation.
Thankfully in computability,
the resolution to this paradox
isn't as hard to see as it is in
set theory or mathematical logic.
We just conclude that
the supposed machine
ML that recognizes
the language L doesn't exist.
Here, it is natural to object,
well, of course it exists.
I just run M on itself and
if it doesn't accept, we accept.
The problem is that M on itself
might loop, or it might just run for
a really long time and
there's no way to tell the difference.
The end result, then is that the
language, L, of string descriptions of
machines that do not accept their own
descriptions is not recognizable.
Recall that in order for a language to
be decidable, both the language and
it's compliment have to be recognizable.
Since L is not recognizable,
it's also not decidable.
And neither is it's compliment,
that is the language where the machine
does accept it's own description.
We'll call this DTM,
D standing for diagonal.
These facts are the foundation for
everything that we will
argue in this lesson.
So make sure that you
understand all these claims.